j'ai deux super smartphone sur la table
j'ai le Galaxy S23 j'ai le Galaxy S23
plus je vais donc vous dire ce que je
pense de ces deux smartphones vous
donner mon retour alors il est juste
qu'on resituer un peu le truc parce que
tout le monde connaît pas les tarifs par
cœur et c'est normal parce que à prendre
des tarifs par cœur ne sert strictement
à rien moi j'ai mes notes donc je vais
tout vous dire le Galaxy S23 il est
dispo dans deux configurations on le
retrouve en 128 et on le retrouve en 256
tandis que le S23 plus est dispo en 256
et en 512 ici on est à 959 euros tandis
que là on est à 1019 euros sur le S23
plus on commence à 1219 euros et on
arrive à 1339 euros voilà ce qu'il en
est au niveau de ses tarifs tout en
sachant que j'ai fait une vidéo pour
vous l'expliquer allez la voir c'est
super intéressant pourquoi parce qu'il y
a une vraie grosse différence sur ce
modèle qui est un peu à part celui avec
128 et la version qui a un peu moins de
1000 balles ça me saoule nos amis ici de
l'uefs 3.1 c'est la technologie de
stockage on a du fs3.0 que soit tous les
autres on a de l'uefs 4.0 ça va fois
moins vite en lecture et en écriture
donc ça leur permet de tirer un tarif un
peu plus bas en dessous des 1000 balles
avec cette techno qui est un peu plus
ancienne mais qui va encore bien alors
il y a plein de différences au niveau de
ces produits je vous en parle également
dans cette vidéo la taille de l'écran la
batterie globalement ce sont les mêmes
au niveau de la photo globalement ils
feront la même chose même si la taille
d'écran change les techno au niveau de
l'écran c'est exactement la même chose
donc il est l'heure aujourd'hui mesdames
messieurs de vous donner mon retour
complet sur les Samsung Galaxy S23 S23
plus j'ai l'impression de faire de la
magie quand je fais ça vous êtes prêt
allez on y va
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec next mobile
vous avez été très nombreux l'autre jour
à aimer le bon plan que je vous ai
partagé avec next mobile pour venir
louer vos Samsung Galaxy S23 et S23
ultra tarif extrêmement canon et vous
avez également très nombreux à recevoir
vos smartphones avec sa coque de
protection et sa protection d'écran
inclus alors aujourd'hui je vous
repartager le bon plan n'oubliez pas
qu'avec le code Mr gros 30 Mr gros GRR
30 vous bénéficiez de 30% de remis sur
l'intégralité de votre première facture
alors regardez je vous remontre et bien
next mobile c'est ça ça vous permet de
venir louer vos smartphones un tarif
extrêmement avantageux on l'a sur le S23
ultra on l'a également sur le S23 ça
vous permet d'avoir votre Galaxy S23 à
39,90 € par mois et votre S23 ultra à
59,90 € par mois sans engagement et ce
qui est très cool et c'est écrit si vous
pouvez changer au bout de 12 mois pour
le modèle supérieur au même prix et sans
apport initial ici sans frais ni hausse
de mensualité Vous avez en plus votre
tranquillité d'esprit avec l'assurance
casse et vol incluse avec qui vous le
marque prise en charge il y a tes
systématique en cas de sinistre sans
oublier que chez NeXT mobile ils ont un
modèle éco-responsable qui redonne une
seconde vie au smartphone en fin de
location tout ça sur un circuit court et
fait en France pensez donc à cette
solution au lieu de venir acheter vos
smartphones vous pouvez également venir
les louer à des tarifs extrêmement
intéressants une fois de plus je vous
mets le lien en bas dans la description
au bout de 12 mois on peut changer sur
le smartphone de la nouvelle génération
ça sera donc le S24 bref que davantage
vous pouvez donc acheter votre
smartphone mais pensez aussi un ex
mobile ça peut être une super solution
et merci annexe mobile d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo alors allons-y
clairement allons-y gaiement je vous
resitue très rapidement les grosses
différences qu'on va venir à voir
différence au niveau de la taille de
l'écran on est d'un côté au moins 6,1
pouces 6,6 de l'autre côté on est sur du
Full HD d'un côté et de l'autre ici il y
a pas de quad HD+ si vous voulez du quad
HD+ il faut venir sur le modèle ultra
j'ai déjà publié une vidéo sur le ultra
allez la voir comme ça vous saurez tout
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement
qui va jusqu'à 120 Hertz ici c'est pas
une dalle ltpo donc on descend pas
jusqu'à 1r sur notre 48 et 120 Hz dans
un cas comme dans l'autre c'est
exactement la même chose vous avez une
différence de batterie 3900 milliampères
heure pour le S23 4700 milliampères
heure pour le S23 plus recherche 25
watts sur le S23 recharge qui va jusqu'à
45 watts sur le S23 plus une meilleure
autonomie fatalement on s'en doutera sur
le modèle plus plus grosse batterie bien
évidemment même si l'écran consomme un
peu plus on est malgré tout sur du
dynamique à molette 2x qui ne consomme
pas énormément au niveau de la dalle
donc ça va on a donc deux smartphones
qui sont très proches et qui auront
exactement la même performance sauf au
niveau de la version 128 Go de stockage
mais une fois de plus vous en parle dans
ma vidéo précédente allez jeter un coup
d’œil déjà la première chose ça va être
au niveau de la prise en main alors
j'enfonce un peu des portes ouvertes si
vous voulez un petit écran tout le monde
n'aime pas d'avoir des très grands
écrans comme sur le ultra 6,8 pouces
c'est hyper massif c'est très très grand
tout le monde ne veut pas dédale
extrêmement énorme tout le monde ne veut
pas des grands smartphone tout le monde
ne veut pas être gigantesque à devoir
tenir à demain si vous voulez un truc un
petit peu plus compact on se parle de
6,1 pouces le format est plus compact on
tient une main et ça c'est vachement
bien donc ça prend pas trop de place
dans une poche ça se glisse partout ça
j'aime beaucoup et un grand bravo à
Samsung là-dessus vous voyez ça descend
bien tandis que si je mets le ultra tout
de suite dans ma poche et bien il
dépasse pas trop mais c'est un peu le
bordel donc vous voyez quand même une
vraie différence donc ça dépend une fois
de plus que vous voulez moi je l'aime
beaucoup le S23 un peu plus petit je
recommande toujours la version 256 pour
avoir la dernière techno de stockage en
ufs 4.0 mais déjà la prise en main est
très très bonne alors après on a
quasiment le même format au niveau de la
largeur ça se tient pas grand chose il y
a quand même une petite différence mais
bon par rapport au modèle ultra c'est
quand même pas tout à fait la même
histoire oui ça raconte pas d'affilée la
même chose c'est un peu plus grand il
est un poil plus large on s'en doutera
le S23 plus donc la prise en main sera
un peu moins bonne et on pourra venir le
chercher à l'utiliser à demain tandis
que le S23 c'est vraiment un smartphone
qu'on vient utiliser une main donc ça
j'aime bien j'adore cette prise en main
je la trouve très canon malgré tout 10,1
pouces c'est pas un petit écran c'est
pas ridicule la dalle est exactement la
même que l'autre donc c'est vraiment une
question de feeling qu'est-ce que vous
préférez un truc un peu plus petit à
venir tenir à une main ou alors un
smartphone un peu plus grand que vous
allez tenir à demain voilà
personnellement je préférerais peut-être
le S23 un peu plus petit ça me plaît
bien ça change parce que comme j'ai
toujours des grands smartphone ça a
changé je l'aime bien mais les deux sont
très bien très honnêtement il y a rien à
raconter là-dessus et un peu la même
chose que j'ai dit sur le ultra ce que
je vais venir reprocher ici au S23 is 23
plus et qui tape trop dans le médium on
manque un petit peu de graves on manque
un peu de rondeur lorsque vous écoutez
comme ça et ça c'est quand même un peu
dommage je préférerais effectivement
avoir un smartphone ou je serai un peu
plus confort au niveau des graves donc
ça c'est le truc qui va manquer un peu à
côté de ça je trouve que la dalle est
quand même assez lumineuse regardez je
peux venir la pousser au tacos à fond
mon petit lapin et c'est lumineux ça me
va bien alors effectivement attention il
y a une différence ici entre le modèle
ultra et les deux autres modèles on est
vraiment dans deux catégories de
produits différents mais en termes de
multimédia il n'a absolument pas à
rougir par rapport aux ultra la qualité
Samsung au niveau de la fabrication de
l'ordre là dynamique à molette 2x marche
super bien donc pour tout ce qui va être
confort multimédia si et ça vous avez
vraiment un smartphone qui marche très
bien qui est très très cool en plus de
ça vous avez ici un Snapdragon 8 GN2 ça
ça veut dire quoi ça c'est le dernier
processeur de Qualcomm que Samsung est
venu nous mettre ici dans leur
smartphone à la place des exinos pour
trouver avant et ça c'est très bien ça
c'est une super nouvelle pourquoi et
bien parce qu'on a vraiment beaucoup de
performances et qu'en plus d'avoir de la
performance on va permettre d'aller plus
loin au niveau de l'autonomie et c'est
là où c'est intéressant parce que alors
que je vous dis sur un modèle vous avez
une batterie sur le S23 de
900 milliampères heure et de l'autre
côté 4700 millions par heure et bien en
fait ce qu'on regarde et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le 4700 Maurs
vient quand même se rapprocher de ce
qu'on a sur le modèle ultra avec une
5000 millions d'erreurs j'écris
tellement mal j'ai tellement honte mais
c'est comme ça donc on a 300 millions
ampères heure d'un côté ou de l'autre de
différence donc en fait ce qu'il faut
vraiment retenir ici c'est que
l'autonomie au niveau du ultra elle est
vraiment super bonne exceptionnelle
l'autonomie au niveau du S23 plus c'est
super bonne l'autonomie au niveau du S23
est très bonne on sera un peu en de ça
mais ça ira quand même vachement bien
une fois de plus il y a une toute légère
différence avec la version 128 256 au
niveau du S23 mais dans l'ensemble
autonomie est quand même bonne donc
voilà ça c'est vraiment cool si vous
voulez pas aller sur l'ultra et si vous
hésitez entre S23 et le S23 plus si
vraiment la question du format n'est pas
importante pour vous allez sur le S23
plus pourquoi plus grosse batterie
meilleure autonomie ça ira un peu plus
loin après ce qui va concerner la
performance pure et dure entre les deux
smartphones c'est la même chose c'est
vraiment la même chose sauf sur la
version 128 256 au niveau du S23 mais
c'est ce que je vous expliquais dans la
vidéo d'avant donc foncez vite la voir
si vous l'avez toujours pas regardé
alors après il y a une autre petite
différence et je vous le disais tout à
l'heure c'est au niveau de la recharge
sur le S 23 vous aurez de la recharge
qui aura uniquement jusqu'en 25 watts
bon ça va pas mal le 25 watts mais c'est
vrai que si on veut la meilleure
expérience on peut monter jusqu'à 45
watts et c'est là où arrive un peu le
truc un peu relou c'est-à-dire que les
blocs de chat aujourd'hui sont plus du
tout inclus donc si vous voulez avoir
votre bug de charge 45 quoi qu'il faut
passer à la caisse tout en sachant que
ce smartphone je vous le disais on est
quand même entre 1219 euros à 1339 € et
il faut venir ajouter un petit truc
comme 40 50 balles et c'est 45 ans de
balles lorsque vous avez déjà mis 1200
balles sur la table je trouve ça con
alors je trouve ça bien et c'est pas que
Samsung attention ils sont nombreux
aujourd'hui à faire ça et j'arrive à
comprendre parce qu'elle est la loi d'un
côté parce que il y a le fait de se dire
on est plus obligé de le mettre et pour
l'écologie c'est bien de pas le mettre
mais de notre côté quand vous avez
quelqu'un qui a payé 1200 balles ou 1300
balles ça serait bien du offrir
peut-être la possibilité mais c'est pas
plus c'est pas que pour Samsung
attention c'est pour les autres aussi
lui dire bon écoutez vous rajoutez 1
euro vous avez le chargeur avec l'idée
c'est pas de se dire je prends un
chargeur pour avoir un chargeur je
prends un bloc de charge pour avoir un
bloc de charge parce que le câble est
déjà fourni la question c'est pas ça
c'est juste de se dire si vous en avez
déjà vous n'en avez pas besoin de
prendre un autre donc auquel cas vous
n'allez pas le prendre vous n'allez pas
de mettre les 1 € de plus pour le
prendre mais on va faire l'effort au
lieu d'augmenter notre mage en mettant
pas de bloc de charge et bien on propose
à ceux qui n'ont pas vraiment de blocs
de charge d'en avoir un pour un tarif
qui est très très réduit vous me direz
vous avez déjà mis 1300 balles dans un
téléphone est-ce que vous êtes à 50
balles près pour moi la réponse reste
quand même oui parce que c'est
symbolique vous mettez beaucoup d'argent
et vous avez pas votre blog de charge
voilà mais c'est pas que ça me saoule
attention c'est vraiment aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'acteurs et surtout dans le
très haut de gamme donc je me dirais que
ça
serait mais si vraiment vous en avez pas
si vous avez un S23 plus et que vous
avez un bloc de charge 25 watts mais
vous voulez en 45 watts et bien je sais
pas moi vous rajouter 5 balles peut-être
10 balles même si c'est pas réellement
le prix du bloc de charge dans le
commerce mais bon vous venez d'acheter
un smartphone il y a plus de 1000 balles
on joue le jeu aujourd'hui si tu ne le
joues pas et je trouve ça un peu con
voilà une fois de plus on passe le truc
il y a de l'écologie c'est bien mais ça
reste une question de marche ok passons
au-delà de cette question tarifaire moi
c'est produit des aime bien je trouve
très cool et on va tous se regarder la
partie la plus importante c'est la
partie photo et pour ça on fait quoi on
se prend un ordi on prend on l'ouvre et
on regarde ça ensemble si vous avez
regardé ma vidéo sur le S23 ultra ma
vidéo test vous serez pas surpris de
retrouver à peu près les mêmes ambiances
au niveau des photos parce que j'en ai
fait plein au même endroit je mutualise
fatalement donc là on est à Amsterdam
photos un petit peu son c'est un hôtel
en fait qui est très sympa à côté de
l'aéroport je vous ai pris quelques
petites photos pour vous mettre un peu
vous montrer l'ambiance là à photo de
nuit on est avec mon pote Anne du
Journal du Geek salut Anne on s'en
doutera il y a une vraie différence
entre ce qu'on peut avoir assis avec un
ultra versus qu'on peut avoir de l'autre
côté avec S23 plus et S23 c'est pas tout
à fait la même ambiance c'est là où on
va effectivement que le ultra va quand
même vachement plus loin au top du top
pour autant ces deux smartphones sont
très très bons en photo là vous le voyez
au niveau de l'ambiance et de la photo
de nuit c'est très cool d'ailleurs je
préfère la deuxième à la première qui
est beaucoup mieux au niveau des noirs
on le voit notamment au niveau des
habits de ad ici l'ambiance au niveau du
chapiteau c'est très chouette là vous
voyez sur l'ultra grand-angle c'est où
j'ai dû bouger parce que je trouve pas
folle là c'est pareil j'aime bien
l'ambiance on retrouve un peu le même
problème qu'on avait sur le S23 ultra
savoir aussi du Lens flair c'est à dire
que c'est vos optiques qui vont faire
ces petites traînées qu'on retrouve qui
sont dues à la lumière ici on va
retrouver un peu partout leur pas
partout vous voyez celle-là je l'ai pas
mais ici je l'ai peut-être parce que je
suis plus sur le côté et que l'optique a
plus de masque sur le côté bon celle-là
j'ai un peu bougé c'est flou mais c'est
de ma faute un peu de matière au niveau
de la corde qu'on vient vraiment voir
ici du détail sur le bois aussi ça c'est
quand même vachement cool le mode
portrait que je trouve aussi super
efficace et super beau il est très beau
sur le ultra et aussi très très beau ici
il a un petit peu de mal vous voyez il a
perdu légèrement mais il avait perdu
aussi sur le ultra là c'est ce petit
truc là que vous avez au niveau de de ma
veste mais sinon dans l'ensemble il est
toujours vraiment bien il est très très
très joli aujourd'hui j'aime bien
franchement c'est vraiment très très
beau je préfère bien évidemment sur
l'ultra mais globalement ici le rendu
est quand même vachement qu'elle est
regardez ça je trouve ça très beau
beaucoup de détails un bon piqué superbe
couleur maîtriser on voit un peu tout
partout bon ultra grand temps je sais
pas pourquoi est-ce que c'est pas ce que
moi je trempe fatalement ça fout un peu
plus le bordel mais il est un peu moins
bon la nuit il sera meilleur sur le sur
le ultra sur son sentir un mais en tout
cas sur le ultra de ce que j'ai pu voir
ça c'est pareil j'aime beaucoup le
détail vous voyez les lumières là mais
malgré tout on voit bien ce qui se passe
au centre donc il y a vraiment un
travail qui se fait au niveau de
l'algodes par zone vous le voyez hein
toute cette partie là là à côté de la
lumière qui vont regarder là toute cette
partie là et ben là il a un peu plus de
mal mais par contre hop là tout le reste
il me le récupère et une fois de plus je
trouve que le boulot est vachement bien
fait très très très bien maîtrisé ici
pareil ça c'est plutôt chouette là c'est
bien sur le côté j'ai retrouvé mes
petits Lens flair qui foute un peu le
bordel mais voilà là ici c'est plutôt
bien alors on voit quand on vient trop
zoomer il se rapprocher de la nuit on a
quoi on a beaucoup de bruit ici c'est
pas beau donc on évite on vient pas
zoomer lorsque je viens trop zoomer vous
voyez c'est l'algo qui vient un petit
peu récupérer mettre les Noirs tout noir
mais par contre on voit qu'on récupère
du bruit ici au niveau du personnage
donc bon on évite quand même je vous
montre quelques autres photos que j'ai
pu faire hop là différents moments ça
marche vraiment bien très honnêtement ça
marche très bien le rendu est très joli
regardez c'est super efficace une fois
de plus ça marche superbe au niveau des
fruits c'est pas mal aussi pour voir
qu'on est dans la nuit il y a quelques
moments où on voit qu'au niveau
d'éclairage un petit peu trop frontaux
il a un petit peu de mal mais ça j'avais
déjà vu également avec le
ultra on pouvait l'avoir sur quelques
scènes mais dans l'ensemble le résultat
est quand même vachement cool regardez
ça ça marche super bien j'aime bien
cette ambiance de fête regardez ça hein
c'est très cool on va bien la personne
devant hop une lumière qui s'arrête la
personne devant coucou toi on a la
personne en face tout est très clair
lisible ça restitue bien en fait
l'ambiance de la soirée l'ambiance du
moment et c'est ça que je veux bien aimé
regardez ça ça marche très très bien
dans un miroir c'est très joli il y a
beaucoup de piquets les couleurs sont là
la caméra ne se le suit fait le taf ou
celui-là il se correct et alors deux
jours ce que j'aime bien également c'est
que et bien l'algo fonctionne très très
bien là je me suis mis vraiment bien
bien bien bien à contre-jour pour autant
j'ai tout j'ai le bâtiment j'ai bien
toutes les côtés ce qui est vraiment
hyper hyper efficace l'ultra grand-angle
va plutôt bien et en plus une
colorimétrie qui est à se maîtriser qui
reste très juste en fait entre le grand
angle et l'ultra grand-angle ça c'est
très très cool également on peut venir
se rapprocher zoom on va éviter on n'est
pas sur l'ultra donc dès qu'on ouvre
davantage voyez on a beaucoup de bruit
ici on a énormément de bruit donc on
vient pas trop trop zoomer on peut
zoomer un peu x 2 x 3 mais au-delà on va
pas trop on a effectivement à fois 3
optique donc ça fait le taf regardez
c'est le grand angle l'ultra grand-angle
c'est très joli et ensuite x 3 on peut
et lorsqu'on vient zoomer davantage ça y
est x 10 on a du bruit regardez ici là
j'ai du bruit donc le X 10 on va venir
vraiment éviter donc si vous voulez
vraiment venir zoomer vous prenez le
ultra où vous avez un tel objectif x 10
optique mais sinon on évite mais par
contre tout ce qui est rendu au niveau
des couleurs c'est très chouette alors
regardez là grand temps ultra
grand-angle et là je vais me rapproche
je vais me rapproche je me rapproche je
vous emmène jusqu'à sur Puy-de-Dôme
quasiment alors une fois de plus c'est
parfait forcément pour c'est pas très
très beau au niveau du rendu mais ça
reste quand même le fond est très joli
alors je vous ai fait quelques petites
photos dans le centre de Clermont et
pour ma part le rendu est vraiment bien
et ça en fait un très très joli
photophone je vous montre un peu de tout
ce que j'ai vu j'ai rien vu qui m'a
choqué voyez au niveau de la gestion des
hautes lumières il est très bonne au
niveau des zones d'ombres il est très
bon il récupère tout lorsque vous venez
trop zoomer il vient très lissé pour
venir récupérer essaie de virer un peu
le bruit on voit là au niveau des des
contours c'est un peu le limite qu'on
peut avoir mais bon c'est globalement
pas mauvais là je suis très exposant
plein soleil là je suis vraiment en
nombre parfaite et pour autant regarder
je vois vraiment tout donc le job est
fait quoi clairement ça me saoule a
vraiment fait le job là vous voyez c'est
très sombre dans une espèce de petit
passage de cave je peux dire zoomer pour
voir la carte je lis pas la carte soyons
clair mais pour autant je peux me
rapprocher un peu alors la caméra de
selfie elle met un peu moins
enthousiasmée que ce que j'ai pu voir
sur l'ultra pour autant on a le même
nombre de mégapixels donc bon c'est très
très cohérent c'est très très bien même
à contre-jour vous voyez sur la caméra
de selfie et bien il va vraiment me
permettre de faire ressortir mon visage
c'est pas trop poussif je trouve qu'au
niveau de l'algo c'est bien fait bien
maîtrisé c'est pas trop exagéré les
couleurs sont assez naturelles toujours
un peu sur saturées Samsung mais là
vraiment ça me choque pas le set un peu
plus bleu que ce que je voyais mais ça
fait le taf donc je peux pas critiquer
je trouve que une fois de plus il
maîtrise vraiment leur appareil une
photo Samsung ici là c'est pareil vous
voyez j'ai le soleil qui est là et pour
autant j'ai bien ma façade de tous mes
bâtiments et même lorsque je viens
zoomer plus dessus donc non non le job
est fait alors là je vous montre
quelques petites photos mais je vais
également vous montrer quelques vidéos
que j'ai pu faire très rapidement dès
que vous avez pas trop de lumière il y a
du bruit un peu de tous les côtés il va
pas être exceptionnel ici vous voyez
c'est très très Bruté j'ai un bruit
numérique un peu tous les côtés bon
voilà on va éviter de venir filmer qu'on
faisait pas beaucoup de lumière mais
pour faire quelques souvenirs on pourra
le faire là où effectivement on voit que
le ultra va beaucoup plus loin avec son
capteur de 200 mégapixels là le capteur
de 50 mégapixels il fait le taf mais il
y a un moment il est un peu plus limité
quand même vous voyez là je suis venu
faire un petit test en zoomant comme ça
et ce qui est très impressionnant est-ce
qu'on avait effectivement avec le
travail qu'on a ici aussi c'est toute la
stabilisation en fait votre smartphone
je le tiens la main comme ça et moi je
tremble donc je l'ai vraiment la main là
et pour autant la stab et là et là je
suis zoom à fond je vais être en X 12
mais une fois de plus ça fait le taf et
ça me surprend parce que c'est vachement
bien regardez alors bon là non ça je
vais trop zoomer c'est dégueulasse
soyons clair mais cette stabilisation
tenue à la main elle est quand même
vachement bleu fond de X et je vais
juste confo 10 sur le S 23 plus c'est
juste qu'on fasse 12 sur le S23 tout
simple mais regardez en le prenant comme
ça il y a rien à dire et je vous montre
même sur la caméra de selfie donc là hop
là je le prends je le balade pour venir
le torturer un peu bon ça fait le taf il
est un peu plus de mal je sais pas si
vous avez vu lorsque moi je viens me
mettre comme ça un petit peu hop là vous
voyez là c'est un peu cramé il a du mal
c'est de la vidéo c'est pas de la photo
on n'a pas les algos qui vont bosser
exactement de la même manière c'est un
peu la limite du système mais au-delà de
ça on va pas s'amuser à se mettre à
contre-jour de toute façon un peu
violente comme ça donc en vidéo on va
éviter mais sinon regardez même là je
fais un arrêt sur image j'ai bien le
détail de l'avare on dirait presque une
photo je trouve ça vachement bien donc
une fois de plus c'est un excellent
photofolle c'est un excellent vidéophone
c'est un excellent smartphone en plus de
ça et si vous connaissez pas bien
l'expérience logiciel du côté de chez
Samsung et bien il faut savoir que vous
avez une superbe expérience logiciel ici
avec One ui 5.1 qui est livré avec
intégré basé sur Android 12 qui est pour
moi une des meilleures expériences
logicielles qu'on peut venir retrouver
ici j'adore on va lui mettre un thème
clair parce que on verra beaucoup mieux
hop là à la caméra c'est très clair
c'est lisible ça marche bien on comprend
tout de suite ce qu'on a sous la main
les paramètres sont une fois de plus
extrêmement lisibles il y a beaucoup de
choses au niveau de la batterie vous
avez de l'optimisation vous avez un mode
maintenance qui vient d'arriver quoi un
nuage 5.1 vous avez plein de mises à
jour et en plus ces trucs qui est
intéressant c'est que Samsung vous
annonce jusqu'à 5 ans 5 ans de mise à
jour de sécurité et 4 ans de mise à jour
Android c'est vrai que vous commencez
avec Android 13 vous aurez ensuite
Android 14 Android 15 Android 16 Android
17 vous allez avoir plein d'Android
Samsung et tous les constructeurs ont
bien compris qu'aujourd'hui les
consommateurs gardent leur smartphone
plus longtemps donc ils font absolument
tout pour que vous puissiez les emmener
le plus loin possible au niveau de la
sécurité au niveau de l'expérience
logicielle pour ne pas avoir de
déconvenue donc ça c'est très très
chouette également et puis bien
évidemment c'est les smartphones sont
certifiés résistants à l'eau et à la
poussière IP68 des deux côtés on a des
indices de réparabilité de 8,2/10 donc
ça c'est très très bon et il y a une
autre truc qui est intéressante et qu'on
va retrouver ici on a du wifi 6 alors
c'est marqué juste ici c'est pas très
évident de le voir mais on a du wifi 6e
l'année dernière sur le S22 ultra on
avait uniquement sur ce smartphone là du
wifi 6e on l'avait pas sur les S22 et
S22+ aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble de la
gamme vous allez retrouver du wifi 6e
S23 S23 plus S23 ultra en attendant le
wifi 7 qui devrait arriver en 2024 dans
les smartphones de Samsung en tout cas
je l'espère peut-être que sur le ultra
les savoirs est-ce qu'il laissera le
wifi 6e sur les deux autres smartphones
pour avoir des tarifs un peu plus
maîtrisés et sur le ultra en wifi 7 ça
pourra arriver on verra ce qui
arriverait l'année prochaine donc bon
d'ici là pensez à vous abonner comme ça
vous serez au courant quand la vidéo du
S24 l'année prochaine potentiellement
arrivera donc ça c'est très cool mais
surtout une fois que je mets sur des
smartphones qui sont complètement
actuels ils ont tout ce qui va bien le
meilleur processeur le super
connectivité vous avez de très très bons
appareils photos ils sont très
performants ils sont endurants il y a
plein de formats en gros vous n'avez que
l'embarras du choix entre ces
smartphones on se sépare vraiment ces
deux familles S23 S23 plus S23 ultra je
les adore je les trouve quand même un
peu cher bien évidemment se parler si du
plus haut de gamme que nous propose
Samsung on commence à 959 euros sur une
version que je vous conseille pas avec
la version 128 Go de stockage je vous
recommande donc de venir commencer sur
la version 256 à 1019 euros tout en
sachant que vous avez encore aujourd'hui
si vous regardez cette vidéo je crois
jusqu'au 16 Samsung sur son site aller
jeter un coup d'œil je vous mets le lien
dans la description on va doubler votre
stockage donc si vous achetez la version
128 vous aurez une version 256 et en
plus de ça vous avez des couleurs
exclusives sur le site de Samsung dont
notamment cette petite couleur un peu
lemon un petit peu entre le jaune et le
vert citron voilà je trouve ça mignon
voilà pour ces smartphones moi je les
aime bien et si vous voulez vraiment
aller sur skymieux en termes de photos
on fait péter le PEL et on va sur le
ultra parce que c'est un excellent
photophone je l'adore il est très très
beau très très bien mais si on veut
quelque chose de vraiment top du ultra
haut de gamme très bien maîtrisé très
joli très bon photo très bon en vidéo
avec un très bel écran une très belle
expérience bref beaucoup de traits et
bien vous allez sur le Samsung Galaxy
S23 s23+ personnellement je trouve que
Samsung a vraiment bien réussi ces
smartphones cette année et une fois de
plus et un truc qu'il n'y a pas pour
rien c'est le fait d'avoir ajouté le
Snapdragon 8 Jane
directement dans ses smartphones pour
moi ça les emmène beaucoup plus haut ça
les positionne beaucoup plus haut que ce
qu'on avait les années précédentes au
niveau des galaxies s donc ça c'est
chouette bravo Samsung dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez est-ce que vous avez
acheté vous un Samsung Galaxy s203 et si
oui dites-moi lequel modèle et puis si
vous ne voulez pas aller sur un de ces
modèles dites-moi pourquoi en bas dans
les commentaires est-ce le prix est-ce
que vous n'aimez pas la marque est-ce
que c'est l'expérience logiciel
qu'est-ce qui vous empêcherait dit d'y
aller marquez moi tout ça en bas dans
les commentaires j'ai hâte de vous lire
je vous embrasse d'ici là prenez soin de
vous et à très bientôt les amis beaucoup
d'amour à bientôt Ciao
[Musique]